So why do we want a multiprocessor?
Why not just use uniprocessors?
Well first, our uniprocessors
would already be 4-wide.
When we got to about 4 to six wide is
when we switch to using multiprocessors
and that's because once
you get to this point,
you get diminishing returns from
making the uniprocessor even wider.
You can make it execute let's say,
six or eight instructions per cycle.
But you don't get as much from
that extension as you did from for
example, making it from two to 4 wide.
And that's because we
get diminishing returns.
If you remember your Amdahl's law, there
will be things that benefit from this,
such as programs that have a lot of
parallelism between instructions.
And then there are things that don't
benefit from this, such as programs that
have a lot of dependencies so
they have to run things one at a time.
Things that are 4-wide already
are already making the parallel
parts fast, whereas the one at
a time parts are not accelerated.
So by the time you get here, you already
have a lot of your program suffer from
not enough parallelism to benefit
from either four or even six wide.
Another problem with uniprocessors,
if we make them even fancier, is,
to make them faster,
we have to jack up the frequency.
To do that, we have to raise the voltage
from what it would be if we'd
use the lower frequency.
And when we do both of these, the power
consumption grows up cubically,
so even if we increase
the frequency by not too much,
we would end up burning our processor.
So we don't really want to make our
uniprocessors be clocked twice as fast
as before and we don't want to make
them much wider than they already are.
But Moore's Law continues.
We get twice the transistors
every 18 months for
the same cot as before and
in the same area as before.
So, we want to benefit from this and
improve the over all performance, but
we no longer can do it this way.
So what do we do?
We just double the number
of cores every 18 months.
That allows us to have the cores
that are not getting wider
that are not getting up in
frequency too much and yet,
the overall computational performance of
the shape is improving with Moore's Law.
So we can get approximately a doubling
of overall performance every 18 months.
That is only if we assume that
we can use all the cores.
If we only have one
program with one thread,
then we're really using
only one of the cores.
It doesn't matter if the number of cores
doubles because we are still using
one of those cores.
So we need programs that
are parallel in order to exploit
our many core processors
that we are getting.
But if we do we continue the trend of
scaling performance up exponentially.
To put this in another way we
have multiprocessors today
not because we think
that we would rather have
twice the cores than twice
the uniprocessor performance.
It's always preferable to have a
uniprocessor, a singe core that is twice
as fast as before than having two
cores that are just as fast as before.
But we ran out of things,
that we can do with uniprocessors.
So after a long string of years
where we were doing this,
just getting better unit processors,
we had to switch to this if we want
to get performance improvement.